know what happened
when the when the beats start falling in
frequency i will
begin um you know people don't
have to um turn off their video i i mean
it's not
um if you would prefer it to be off
that's fine
um but um um
i know of some people who say that it
um kind of builds the opportunity to
keep the video running but
anyways it's up to you and i know some
people
um are not dressed as well as they might
want to be or
eating lunch or breakfast or whatever
um well good why don't we why don't we
go ahead and get started
i want to welcome everyone to a special
[Music]
edition of the d mice research
conference which typically happens
at the end of academic terms because
there are
often students who are
either defending proposals or defending
theses or dissertations or
giving their capstones or symposium or
or whatever so we always have
um more than we just fit into once a
week so we schedule them at these
slightly off times
um which are probably easier to make
these days because most of us
are sitting at home so anyways
today we're going to have a phd
dissertation
proposal defense and the purpose of a
proposal defense is
for the candidate to describe the work
that they're doing
for a larger audience namely the
department and anyone else who's
attending
our research conference and
it gives many different people an
opportunity to
respond to critique even give
suggestions
before the student pursues their in this
case dissertation
and the same thing for a thesis master's
thesis proposal defense
so our speaker this morning is mina
mishra who
most of you know because she's been
around the department
for a couple years and she's a phd
candidate she's also a national library
medicine fellow
in the health and clinical informatics
major
she before she started our program
she was a certified clinical research
professional
and spends her time managing and
coordinating clinical trials and
oncology and bone marrow transplant at
the doernbecher
children's hospital she has two master's
degrees one in
biotechnology from banaras hindu
university
in varanasi india and also a masters of
public health from the university of
south
carolina um her interests are in the
secondary
use of electronic health record data
in particular using that data to enhance
the knowledge
about diseases and effectiveness
treatments her
current research interest which she'll
describe to us
is in exploring the effectiveness and
unintended consequences
of implementing clinical practice
guidelines in the ehr
so she is defending her dissertation
proposal she will
initially give us a presentation and
then
there will be time for question and
answer and then um
or her um dissertation advisory
committee may
um wish uh to spend some additional time
with her
uh when she's done so i'm going to turn
the floor over to mina
thank you dr hush um
when can you take this and give me the
appropriation to
share my i don't i don't have host
privileges at the moment
oh okay i wonder if
diane diane diane is the host
so okay yes how do i give mina the
rights to share lynn
oh there it goes yeah there it goes it's
sharing
okay okay
yeah i was at a meeting yesterday and
there was quite a delay
between the time the person clicked
share and the time it showed up
sorry that was not okay
good morning everyone thanks for being
here for my proposal defense
um so the topic of my research proposal
is bridging the gaps
between evidence and practice of
assessing risk and addressing harms
for adults on chronic opioid therapy
essentially i'll be looking
at an assessing system readiness and how
it affects
the task of risk assessment
uh the roadmap for my presentation will
include the background gaps from
literature
my research framework and the questions
methods and analysis for each of my aims
i'll end with the deliverables and how
they
will add value to the current stage of
affairs and i'll finish my talk with the
timeline
so the landscape of primary care is
changing
actually the landscape of the healthcare
is changing
essentially to address the quantum means
of improved quality
improved outcomes reduced cost
improved provider experience and the
most recent addition to this
these aims the improved equity
there is a growing awareness that
individual health is tied to
social environmental and community
determinants of health
the affordable care act is based on this
premise
as a result of various reports that have
come out of
a institute of medicine now known as
national academy of medicine
there is a move towards integrating
primary care and public
health to better support the patients
families and the caregivers
so our pcps or the primary care
providers are the first contact
and access to care for patients primary
care visits make up about half of all
physician
office visits um based uh this figure is
based
off of the national ambulatory medical
care survey of 2016.
about more than half of these primary
care visits involve
one or more chronic condition and one in
five of these visits involve
three or more chronic conditions
and the scope of primary care practice
is huge if we
consider it by means of the number of
icd
codes that are used in the primary care
practice uh
primary care providers use almost twice
the number of ict codes than other
specialties
so we've already established how complex
that primary tier setting is
and how complex the primary care serving
population is
in addition primary care physicians are
experiencing burnout
according to the 2018 survey of
america's physicians
uh 78 of the physicians report
sometimes often are always experiencing
the feeling of burnout
the two factors that are least
satisfying about medicine
medicine for most physicians are the ehr
design and interoperability
and the regulatory and insurance
requirements uh more than half of the
physicians feel that
ehr reduces their efficiency
so if you take a minute to consider the
friedman's fundamental theorem
of biomedical informatics which states
that
a person assisted by an information
resource
is better than a first person that acts
unassisted
um then and and we can
we consider one of the three corollaries
that accompanies this theorem
that the resource information resource
should be
formatted informative and
in essence the resource should provide a
new
new information and the information
should be correct and actionable
so if we consider this uh theorem and
the correlatory
uh we arrive at the fact that uh
the ehr as an information resource
needs improvement uh to better assist
primary care providers
in their complex information needs
and what my research proposal strives to
do is exactly that
i seek to develop a generalized pipeline
to identify the information needs of
primary care providers
and information readiness of the
information uh resource in this case ehr
so that we can improve
this uh this information resource that
the physicians have
to deliver better care
and to develop this pipeline i'm looking
at the use case of
pcps doing a
risk assessment for their patients on
chronic opioid therapy
and using opioids tcps prescribe
about half of all prescription opioids
and manage
most chronic pain patients and the 2006
cdc guidelines
calls and recommends pcps to weigh the
risk and benefit
when prescribing opioids
so to look at more closely uh
at some of the data about this epidemic
and the prescription opioids role in
this epidemic
about 21 to 29 of the patients
uh who are prescribed opioids for
chronic pain
misuse them eight to twelve percent
develop
opioid use disorder or oud uh four to
six percent uh
who misused transition to heroin and
about eighty percent of the people who
use heroin first misuse prescription
opioids
um and uh oud is associated with
considerable morbidity and mortality
which uh lends itself to a huge economic
burden
um and the mortality rates uh for a
person with oud
is ten times higher than that of an
average population
so um so so risk for uh
from opioid prescription opioids can be
reduced if you follow the guidelines
uh screening and monitoring patients for
misuse abuse and opioid use disorder
uh and uh these these are the three
categories of recommendations that cdc
guidelines
um has uh have
uh and i'm more specifically looking at
the third category which is assessing
risk and addressing harm
so there are various uh risk factors
for all the different opioid related
harms
the misuse abuse and oud and several of
them
are present in the guidelines themselves
like looking uh
for patients history of overdose uh
patient history of substance use
disorder
uh a patient being on a high dose of
opioids
uh so they are the guidelines uh
recommends
uh to look into that when you're
considering uh opioids for risk for
overdose
there are also several risk factors uh
from literature
uh that suggests high risk for misuse
like
family history of substance abuse or
personal history of substance abuse
younger age etc so all these different
opioid related harms are associated with
different risk concepts
um if we look at the opioid use disorder
in particular
it is a highly heterogeneous condition
the diagnosis of this disorder needs uh
the patients to meet uh two at least two
of the 11 symptoms
from four different concepts uh and
these concepts
are impaired control social impairment
risky use and some some pharmacological
properties of tolerance in the draw
the oud disorder actually ranges
from mild to severe and
to get to the diagnosis uh
the providers often use screening tools
or they look into the ehr
for certain aberrant drug related
behavior oftentimes these
uh these adrbs are
unsystematically documented uh and
and and structured notes
um so if you look at the problem of
uh chronic pain and addiction
uh they both have an underlying biocycle
psychosocial context
which means that to to
address these problems the physician
needs to integrate multiple
types of data biological psychological
social and and certain uh
factors that are that act as a mediating
factors
to uh precipitate um
addiction um
so uh if you look into uh
literature there are several gaps uh
that suggests that
um that the information needs of pcps
uh there are gaps in the understand in
understanding the information needs of
the pcps
uh when they are assessing risk and
addressing harm
uh so for example there is no one risk
tool
uh success risk assessment tool that can
guarantee accurate risk
for any one patient uh the lack of
evidence about the role of adrb in
undefined problem opioid use
um is is there and there is also
a lack of understanding about uh the
role of social development determinants
in risk assessment and harm reduction
there are also gaps in the readiness of
ehr to
address the information needs of the
pcps
identifying problem opioid has been
difficult
due to inconsistent problem opioid
terminologies
and variation in documentation practices
there's also inconsistent use and
documentation of standardized screening
tools
which adds to the ehr
readiness level uh to at the point of
care
so my central hypothesis for the
research study is that the current ehr
system does not address information
needs of pcps
to perform efficient and effective risk
assessment at the point of care
and to do this i am proposing
uh this research framework um under
the aim one i will identify the
information needs
um by doing some literature review of
the guidelines and peer-reviewed
literature
the second part of my aim one will
encompass prioritizing these information
needs by using the modified
pi survey aim two will be to evaluate
the information
readiness uh the data quality assessment
uh of the data the high rank concepts
from m1 will be assessed using a
harmonized data quality framework
the aim pre will uh um will address uh
will
uh will involve in evaluating the impact
of information readiness
so i will look at the performance of
a few clinically relevant measures
and see how they perform
in the current state of information
readiness
so this is the question that i'm trying
to answer
as a part of my aim once um what are the
high ranking concepts
for risk assessment um so
in order to address the question i will
be determining the high ranking concepts
and the second question that i'm asking
as a part of a1 is does the need for
certain concepts
change based on healthcare settings and
are we getting ready for that
uh sorry i hear somebody say something
is there a question
so aim one um is
the first part of aim one is essentially
a very exhaustive
literature review uh the steps would
include
uh conducting a search of uh
guidelines and best practices out there
and also some peer-reviewed scientific
literature
from pubmed and scopus i have already
done uh preliminary research
and come up with uh 269 articles i've
used mesh terms for chronic pain opioids
opioid related risks and outcomes
and i have uh i have a
initial list of 259 articles that i'll
be going through
uh i've developed my uh inclusion and
exclusion criteria
basically looking at the articles that
have a
population that are adult and primary
care physicians
conditions that include chronic uh
long-term non-malignant pain
medications that are uh that include
prescription opioids and outcomes
that are uh relevant for the study that
i'm doing
all opioid related outcomes of like
misuse abuse addiction overdose
um and the objective of articles will
also be considered
uh basically i'm looking at articles
that will uh that have
uh that are looking at risk factors or
predictors
for the above outcomes uh the exclusion
criteria would include any condition
that are uh that does uh that that
includes palliative care malignancy
fastest care cancer and i'm including
articles that are
um from that from usa and canada just
because the guidelines for
uh risk assessment uh of these countries
are
very similar
so already from preliminary research
i i see that the the four
outcomes that physicians are tasked
with monitoring uh for uh monitoring in
their
care uh they have um several risk
factors that overlap but there are also
several risk factors that are
specific to these um
these outcomes um and so this would be
uh
very very uh helpful when i'm designing
my survey
the second part of my uh aim one is
essentially doing a modified delphi
survey to rank
all the opioid risk concepts that i come
across from literature review and
talking to the
stakeholders um so i
will be developing and writing the
survey
and amplifying experts for my survey and
administer at least two rounds of
modified delphi survey
uh my the main goal of this aim one
is to reach a consensus on most needed
risk concepts
to assess risk for patients on cot for
plants of
course basically chronic opioid therapy
for for
for pain so this
is uh my modified l5 process
uh to uh the round one
is basically the thesis stage in which
i'm collecting
uh and there's exhaustive search which
is your search for all the opio address
concepts for risk assessment and harm
reduction in primary care setting
uh the round two uh um surround one uh
in in a delphi survey is essentially a
qualitative survey to collect
all the concepts but i am
modifying the delphi process by doing
the collection
uh by doing the literature review the
round two
would be the first round of survey where
i will use the
survey to elect the need for each
um concepts risk concepts
uh uh very high to very low
and the round three is the synthesis
stage uh of my modified pro
delphi process where
the physicians or the participants of
the delphi
survey would be asked to re-evaluate
their response for each concepts
and so the purpose of this of this
process is to arrive at a consensus
uh how important a particular risk
concept is for providers to assess risk
for their patient population
so the most important part of the
modified l5 survey is uh
defining the experts and for the purpose
of model 5 survey i am
going to be recruiting physicians who
routinely manage patients on opioids for
chronic non-malignant non-end of life
pain
in past studies uh it appears that
uh the experts being considered for this
type of survey
are who are at least seeing at least
four or more patients of this type
and that's what i will use for defining
my survey experts
my sample size would include a purpose
example of 30 experts and the setting
would be a diverse primary care setting
family medicine internal medicine women
health center and the purpose of using
including women health centers they
could be risk factors that are
specific to gender
and women may have a slightly different
risk factors than and then
males um and uh
basically i'm trying to include rural
rural and urban participants
uh and participants from academic health
center and federally qualified health
center
the the delphi survey will use
the red cap the most recent version
that's at ohsu
um all of my survey items uh
will be closed uh likert scale
uh survey items uh from very low to very
high
uh except for one uh i will include one
single open question to include any
additional concept that i may have
missed
so this is a sample of my modified lsi
survey
basically it shows all the you know
identified risk concepts and
request uh providers uh when considering
opioid prescription
uh how do how helpful they find these
responses
in the at the point of care um and the
last one
on the sample is the box for providers
to provide additional concepts that i
may have missed
so this is essentially the analysis
of my first round of delphi survey which
would
include uh doing a descriptive
statistics for each of the risk concepts
um doing the central measures and
measures of center tendency and
dispersion and there will be an
uh on the open question that i have on
the survey i will do a content analysis
to
determine if there are any new concepts
that i can include with the second round
of delphi survey
the consistent consensus definition for
the risk concepts
is uh if any of this concept
reach uh more than 75 percent of the
participants rate that press concept
as high or very high as uh we will
i will undefine a data consensus has
been reached for that response up
uh so this is how the structure of round
two would look like
basically the descriptive statistics
from round one
for each of the concepts together with
the individual responses of each
participant will be shared
new concepts that arise from the
qualitative response will also be shared
and the participants will be asked to
reflect and re-evaluate the responses
uh the analysis of round two survey
would include the mean and consensus
level for each risk concept
um and uh the risk concepts will be
ranked based on their mean score
and the results from round one and round
two will be compared using a pair t-test
and the results for different groups or
the settings that i've included in my
research study will be compared using
appropriate parametric or not
parametric tests
so a rigor reliability and validity
is a very important aspect of a mixed
method study
and i will try to maintain rigor by
striving to have uh maintain a response
rate of seventy percent
uh uh or more for each round uh
the reliability will be maintained uh
by um you know i'm doing a very
extensive exhaustive upfront collection
of concepts
using peer-reviewed studies and inputs
from stakeholders and that will ensure
uh reliability reliability to some
extent
also the very uh uh
design iterative very design of delphi
process
also seeks to improve the reliability uh
especially since i'm seeking
um response from
several experts as uh as a part of my
study design
the validity will be ensured by um
by the quasi anonymous study design
uh this reduces bias and
participants are less likely to be
influenced by how their peers
answer on any risk concept
and also including experts from various
different settings
increases the external validity of my
findings
so this is again we approached the
research framework
the aim 2 is what i'm going to address
next
which is to evaluate the information
readiness
and the way i'm going to do this is the
question that i'm asking at the part of
m2 is are are the high rank risk
concepts that we identified from
aim 1 are they easily available in ehr
and the ease of availability uh is uh
the presence of a risk concept in a
structured or discrete field
is taken as a proxy for ease of
availability
uh the second question that i'm trying
to answer and into
is what is the quality of the risk
concepts um
so once we determine are they present in
the structure and discrete field
uh what does the quality look like does
the does the response
inform risk for the patients
uh there is a reach aim uh as a part of
the aim2 uh
i would like to determine if the
availability and quality of high
rank risk concepts depend on patient
characteristics
so the material that i am proposing to
obtain is a de-identified data set from
research data warehouse of adult
patients on opioids
for non-malignant non-end of life pain
between january 2016
and december 2019 and i'm choosing that
time point because uh 2016 is one of the
cdc guidelines came out
uh 2017 uh you know saw
that guidelines being disseminated
and implemented uh in in the ehr
so um so that's the reason for
choosing that specific time point
so i already have a strategy for two uh
for the rdw to extract
the initial cohort that i'm interested
in and this strategy
was developed based on the guidance from
the cdc document
basically i'm looking at patients over
18 years
who are opioids based on the national uh
drug
uh classification codes
and uh basically these patients need
not have any of the icd codes linked to
malignancy
they shouldn't be on any medication that
are not otherwise used in the outpatient
setting
uh and they should meet the description
of uh chronic opioid use
and the definition is again taken from
uh the one recommended by the cdc
um so at the end of the this uh strategy
i hope to get my initial cohort of adult
patients
um who are on chronic um
opioid therapy for non-malignant
non-end-of-life pain
uh so uh here is a the method
uh in order for me to
determine um which of the highland
concepts
are present in the structured field um i
will have
do some informational interviews with
the pcps
to determine which of the high rank
concepts that are identified from
m1 exist in the structured or discrete
field in the ehr
and so use that as a starting point for
my aim too
these high rank concepts will be
extracted from the rdw
uh from the initial cohort that has been
identified
so basically this is showing the
analysis for determining
uh you know what proportion of the
structured uh
high rank concepts for all the higher
end concepts that
i identify in aim one what proportion of
those
exist in a structured field and of the
uh of this hierarchy concepts that exist
in the structured field
what proportion of the court patients
have those
uh higher end concepts and these are
this is these are
important information to have if we want
to improve
our ehr system
again uh the aim two the second part of
my into uh
is determining the quality of these uh
highland quan structured high rank
concepts
in order to do to do so i will do some
manual chart review on random sample of
patients
uh in the de-undefined data set uh so
i'm hoping to do a cohort
uh use the cohort discovery discovery
tool to
get an initial sense of what my size of
uh the the identified
data set would look like in order to
determine the n
for my random sample and the quality
dimensions that i will be looking at
is completeness correctness and currency
so this is uh what i will be
doing and how i'll be defining
the completeness and correctness i will
define it based on hogan wagner's method
basically he they
use the sensitivity metrics for
completeness
and the positive predictive value
metrics for
correctness or accuracy and that's what
i will be using for my high rank
structured concepts
uh the currency of uh the concept will
be determined based on whether it falls
within the required timeline
um according to the cdc guidelines or
to inform the risk determination
so as i mentioned i have one reach aim
as a part of my m2 which is to determine
if the availability and the quality of
high-risk concept depend on patient
characteristics
and the reason i'm doing this is because
uh it appears from literature that
race and gender uh
plays a bigger role in um
and and risk assessment activities being
performed
than uh actual risk factors
um so this is to validate um this
finding uh
so that we have a useful information uh
and we can use
that to address uh uh
to address uh it in a later uh at a
uh in in practice so i will be
developing
a multivariate regression model to
determine if patient characteristics
such as
ethnicity race gender income level
insurance types
predict data quality of high rank
responses
so at the end of aim 2 i
hope to come up with a prioritization
matrix
of all my high rank risk concepts
and this will add to the value uh
for future informatics projects
uh so again um this uh this is my
research framework
again and i will now proceed to aim
three which is evaluating the impact of
information readiness
and in order to to do that i will
[Music]
look at the performance of some
clinically relevant quality measures
so in a recent um study by alan at all
um it was determined uh especially
essentially by a modified alpha process
that
uh five uh these five
uh outcomes um
are important or and clinically relevant
when we are looking at clinical
guidelines
and its effect um and i will be using
the results from the study
and coming up with some measures
uh to see how they perform
uh based on the the
structured and unstructured data in ehr
so basically i'll be looking at a a risk
adjusted
a measure that is based uh off of the
risk adjusted change
in peg score
i will also be looking at proportion of
patients assessed for opioid abuse
risk before initiating opioids by
whether an opioid risk tool or other
screening tool were used to assess the
risk
and what proportion of patients were
assessed for aberrant drug ridge
behavior
um like what proportion of patients had
their pdmp checked or
urine drug testing done and the
proportion of patients that signed a
treatment agreement prior to opioid
initiation
these are measures based off of
recommendation in the cdc guidelines
and their performance based on the data
that currently
is housed in the ehr as a result of the
care
can uh throw some light as to uh you
know if you were to move towards
uh uh you know um evaluating the effect
of clinical guidelines
um are is the data in ehr ready to
address that
um so again in order to accomplish my
aim three i'll be doing a chart review
to extract critical concepts
for the four outcome measures are using
the structured and unstructured data
the performance and 95 percent
confidence interval will be computed for
each of the measures
and this will be used to
as a
basis for future projects to improve the
ehr
so as a result of my research proposal
um
the deliverables uh that uh specific
deliberate
deliverables that i have is a better
understanding of the data needs and the
availability at the point of care
i'm also hoping to develop a framework
or a pipeline
uh that that looks at
undefined information needs and
assessing information readiness
uh especially in context of a primary
care setting which is highly complex
with highly complex data needs
information needs um i i'm also
coming up with a prioritization matrix
that can inform future
projects uh like creating cds or
implementing ecqms
or even developing a probabilistic risk
strategy stratification
uh model um
so uh so my timeline um
looks a little busy but i hope to
uh stagger my uh proposal
uh uh across
the whole entire 2021 and i hope to be
done by
the the winter time of 2022
um as planned this is what the plan
looks like
um i have some uh some
cushion to in case something unexpected
comes up
but this is my timeline
um in the end i would like to
acknowledge my dissertation advisory
committee
uh steven bedrich nicole weisbach
steve kasakian and dana womack uh the
demise faculty
which has been a huge help dr paul
garman
michelle ripper and chris hoekstra the
staff
dying doctor and lynn schwabe and the
students adam drewell and ben sanders
who provided me with valuable feedbacks
um uh my mentors dr mary pickett
who i've been pestering since i started
uh i got
gotten interested in this project and
jonathan robbins whom i have shadowed in
the clinic
and i am extremely extremely thankful
for the national library of medicine
for this opportunity um
thank you and i'm ready for questions
great um there have um there's a few
a little bit of discussion going on in
the um
in the chat i don't know if you have any
um
response to that i mean and then other
people can either type things into the
chat or
unmute themselves and and ask questions
okay uh let's see
um
does rdw include data from pdmp
to capture prescription from outside of
ohsu system that's a good question
um and which i believe the pdmp
is the um the system that's used to
um monitor certain types of drugs
including opioids
that patients may get at multiple
locations
but i'm i'm not the expert here
yeah yeah you're right uh so pdmp is the
prescription drug monitoring program
which
is run by the state uh different
authorities state
authorities run different states
so so yes the rdw
data would not reflect uh
if uh if the patient
uh acquired opioids
from uh providers outside
of uh the ohsu system
or uh any data that exists in pdmp will
not be in the red
rdw system um um
so so that's a good point um
so that do you then
do you have any additional concern if
this thing is missed i know the
providers
try to reconcile medications with their
patients
and they are there is recommendation for
them to check the pdmp
and do that um but how often it will be
done that will be a limitation of the
study oh yeah i just wanted to
you know bring that up as a thought
about it i agree maybe that will be
reflected in the way their
workflows that they already do um but
but in terms of gathering data to to
document
what's available to the providers um
that might be missing because
as as we know uh many folks that are
on the road towards inappropriate use
will
uh get prescriptions from many folks and
that's where that's why the
pdmp network has was uh has been
established but
but uh so i guess i would just ask you
uh what you know
what would be the upper downside to that
to having access to that data
yeah that's probably another study but
definitely
that that will be a limitation here um
uh okay so i have
pdmp ssd data is generally not captured
in the local ehr
samina there's been a lot of back and
forth in the chat about what data do and
do not end up in the rdw
um and i think the the overall take home
with that is
increasingly there are data from care
everywhere that are flowing into
our epic background but that's been
fairly recent i don't know how much
that's going to impact your time period
of interest
um i'm also not sure off the top of my
head if that means the data are also
ending
up in the rdw
and then mary pickett had another
question
or comment in the chat um
yeah then how to take a step up yeah the
hardest part of this may end up being
validating the diagnosis of oud
primary care doctors are not always
confident about their diagnosis and not
always right and the patients often
don't acknowledge
they have oud even if the doctor
believed them to
it would be helpful to think about
working with addiction medicine
specialist and work
background backwards from confirmed
cases to chart makers flag that are okay
yeah so mary what you are uh trying to
get to
is a project that would be uh a
downstream from this
um i i i'm certainly interested in
making
the diagnosis of oud
more um aminable
and doable for primary care providers
and and if there is
a probabilistic
a risk stratification model that i can
come up with
i can i can look at this initial project
as collecting all features that would go
into that model
uh but that's something that i'm
interested in will be downstream from
this
any other questions but i did my cat
strategy did not capture us okay
yeah um i'm sorry if i missed anybody
and
i do not do very well when i read
under sure so if i miss anybody please
uh please uh
uh you're welcome to uh voice your
concern
i think those were the two main things
that were being discussed in the chat
while you were presenting
okay
i finished early um i had a lot of other
slides but
i was not sure if
um i should present them all
as so i left a lot of
time for question manager um feel free
to
to ask any
well um no that that that's fine um
it's um um you know if there's any uh
questions you want to ask of us you know
otherwise we can
give people uh 10 minutes of their day
back
okay okay now i don't know if your
committee wants to stick around you can
decide that with them
but thank you everyone and we'll have
another
conference tomorrow at the usual time so
hope to see most of you then take care